si se ha pactado un nuevo cese al fuego
en la ciudad de mariupol para permitir
la evacuación de las decenas de miles de
civiles que se encuentran en esta ciudad
duramente bombardeada en los pasados
días según han informado las autoridades
locales estas este este domingo a partir
de las 10 de la mañana y hasta las 9 de
la noche se permitirá la salida de estas
personas esta noticia a este acuerdo
llega después de que ayer se tuviera que
interrumpir las operaciones de
evacuación debido a que rusia no daba
las garantías de interrumpir las
actividades bélicas según la versión
dada por las autoridades ucranianas y
también tenemos informaciones de que las
tropas rusas se estarían dirigiendo
hacia la central eléctrica hacia una
central eléctrica que está a 100
kilómetros de quiebre en el sur por
tanto también esto demuestra que siguen
esas operaciones de intento de dañar las
estructuras estratégicas de ucrania por
parte de rusia y nosotros en ruta
seguimos viendo también imágenes de
decenas de ucranianos que están
construyendo trincheras en campos que
antes se usaban para para cultivar
productos agrícolas son realmente
imágenes de guerras de otros tiempos